hmm yeah hello and welcome to this video
somehow I got totally confused here and
let's see FM elias looking weird on the
screen narration actually switch on the
lights g6 what the beep it's a big
benoni guy playing the Benoni with a
couple of tempe down don't mind dad
maybe wants to trick me into a
defaulting thinking I have no idea
what's going on there it's not really
the case
let's just prevent the counter play here
and then see what's going on rupee one
and then potentially five or bishop age
6 Fitz engine probably all scenarios d 1
yeah but this is this kind of structure
is pretty terrible to be honest because
he he gets immediately killed on c5 now
this type of thing ahead on the board
multiple times a 594 comes it's pretty
bad
okay so how do I do this night if four
you can probably can take I can go F 3
and Queen f2 yeah let's do this
it's not such a bad move anyway it fits
into the structure quite well and can
get whole to seem keep the pawn another
ideas also must be five ticks on c5 so
if i go here he will really plain aight
aight aight right ok mm-hmm before take
c5 yep can't repair that you probably
will go a short castle and at five
somehow but that's not going to work if
i do this before take c5 here's a way to
set between so he has to go to that
we're def six square well or to c7
obviate but that doesn't look like a
picnic either
no f5 76-95 to win material why is that
already is that too little maybe
oh it almost feels like it's not enough
maybe I'm going over here actually
prepared Bishop g5 winning the Queen and
it also helps with those ideas with d6
so churchy 5 hmm
we showed you five Queen h5 not not
clear that i'm winning the Queen it
looks very close to that but not not
completely not completely winning the
Queen so yeah do six is ok ok let's do
this I don't know
so we had a couple of good news here
actually Bishop c4 yeah maybe Bishop c4
pinning pinning the eff porn twin night
on a eight we can actually move it now
that's something that I should have seen
actually probably I can play Luke takes
b7 here I didn't do that to the I didn't
play that well I mean that already was
far more winning than this and this is
really a lot more now anyway so let's
see that I at least the winter stuff to
be a bit heartbreaking not to okay so
went here okay Bishop is six rupee seven
Wow but that means the Queen doesn't it
isn't that when the Queen Bishop g5 he
has no squares at the end and I hope I'm
not miscalculating that would be
somewhat embarrassing Bishop h6 maybe
but I thought he would lose the Queen
here Bishop g5 Bishop e7 Bishop g5 Queen
h5 Bishop g4 wins the Queen okay so he
reacted to that then be seven should do
the trick d 7 hi Bonnie yes
yeah it probably wasn't the most
convincing way to to win this with okay
I take a check check check black resides
and I mean considering how we at flex
position is I really probably should
have done that badass among okay it's
something like this and c6 was winning
and then PA yeah this is a trap piece
hmm you know yeah okay b6 redid that
should also do the trick I mean the
position just looks too bad but it
wasn't wasn't the best it wasn't simply
wasn't the best and I'm happy that I
remedies that I'm at least winning and
not having screw it up totally so the
point was that this Bishop g5 wins the
Queen I saw this idea a little bit
earlier in the game and but he always
had this square which is not available
now so that was the queen trap and here
the deep one is promoting so what's
important motif I mean to the opening is
this really a bit strange share that he
played 26 maybe that was a finger
failure somehow some Mouse lip and so he
gets a bin own here to tempt me down but
this is should not this is just not
working 95 because it gets to this to
this kind of structure and here he just
next time if he has a little bit ton of
time here and he would be able to play
both a 5 and b6 then he would would hold
the Queen side but he cannot do this
anymore yeah it looks like that there's
a five and now this is just not not
possible to hold you have the engine
before already maybe you can probably
play it in this brutal brutal fashion
but this is just structurally speaking
it is too bad I mean I took a bit of
time with what I did but it always leads
to this kind of scenario where blacks
pieces are just yeah quite so quite
quite funny this situation yeah we solve
is all the rest basically so this is
something to remember this is a really
awful porn structure white gets an A
five if you can block it and get a night
26 like 85 be 69 over to d6 this is not
so bad with the way it is here it's
basically lost I mean with good good
play from white okay thanks for watching
I forgot to get their analysis in if you
wonder what the engine things about this
it's like on plus two already okay
thanks for watching